et mobilisation parisienne également
aujourd'hui en soutien au peuple
palestinien
également demain cette fois autorisée
elles devront toutefois rester statique
après décision du préfet mobilisation
qui intervient après les affrontements
sanglants de ces derniers jours entre le
hamas et l'armée israélienne ne retourne
notre reporter lucas léger
bonjour à luquet alors comment ça se
passe actuellement est bien mira
actuellement mais bien la pluie battante
à un petit peu dispersé la foule mais
vous pouvez voir tout de même des rats -
qui se sont encore peu nombreux ici sur
la place de la république ils ont
déployé un grand drapeau palestinien on
soutien au peuple palestinien
après les bombardements de l'armée de
tsahal pendant 11 jours sur la bande de
gaza des bombardements qui en fait un
des plusieurs dizaines et des centaines
de morts je suis justement avec nicolas
shahshahani de l'organisation
europalestine à des participants à cette
manifestation bonjour monsieur chat et
bien qui est l'intérêt de manifester
alors qu'il ya eu un cessez le feu
actuellement il ya eu un cessez le feu
espérant qu'il va tenir après onze jours
de bombardements parmi les plus
intensifs que le régime israélien terme
est déversée sur la bande de gaza avec
vous avez commencé à le citer un bilan
ou en centaines de morts
en milliers de blessés et des
destructions absolument est épouvantable
et puis à peine le cessez le feu et il
proclamé que la police israélienne
attaque de nouveau les palestiniens dans
leur sanctuaire c'est à dire la mosquée
al aqsa de jérusalem
l'un des lieux les plus saints de
l'islam et essayer une certaine logique
à ça c'est que israël après s'être gorgé
de violences extrêmes pendant 11 jours
contre la bande de gaza poursuit son
entreprise d'occupation de colonisation
qui et d'expulsion des palestiniens qui
je vous le rappelle ceux du quartier de
cheikh jarrah à jérusalem cette
tentative d'expulsion est précisément ce
qui a mis le feu aux poudres de manière
plus violente encore avec la riposte des
roquettes palestiniennes de gaza vers le
territoire israélien et à linverse une
redoublée des bombardements israéliens
sur la bande de gaza donc
je réunir manifester notre colère exiger
des sanctions contre le régime
d'apartheid et à commencer par le
boycott d'israël je vous rappelle à ce
propos que malgré les poursuites
constante du lobby israélien en france
la présidente de notre association et
les biens est mort a gagné son procès
l'autre jour à lyon
à procès qui lui a été fait parce que
notre site europalestine points comme
appel au boycott de cette entreprise qui
finance le budget de l'armée israëlienne
merci beaucoup merci est à noter que
donc demain une autre manifestation est
organisée et là encore la préfecture de
police a refusé qu'il y ait un cortège
comme c'est le cas aujourd'hui
la préfecture de police a refusé qu'il y
ait un cortège jusqu'à la place de la
madeleine
merci à lucas pour toutes ces précisions